the fbi apparently having finished its
investigation into bubba wallace's
garage door pull and looking for a new
dragon to slay showed up yesterday at
the home of a trump supporting
former twitter troll and took him into
custody on charges of as a press release
from the doj puts it
depriving individuals of their
constitutional right to vote
the formal criminal complaint alleges
more specifically that the accused
douglas mackey
a.k.a ricky vaughn that's the the name
of his uh
if his twitter account which has been
suspended for years now
they say he conspired to quote injure
oppress
threaten and intimidate persons in the
free exercise of a right and privilege
secured to them by the constitution
the rest of the complaint makes it clear
that all of this supposed
injuring oppressing threatening and
intimidating
was conducted in the form of memes
mackie faces 10 years in federal prison
for memes
now admittedly it's not a great shock i
guess to find joe biden's government
arresting and prosecuting people for
posting memes if there's any surprise
here it's perhaps
only that it took less than two weeks to
get to this point
the new york times has some more details
on the case they say federal prosecutors
accused douglas mackey 31 of
coordinating with co-conspirators to
spread memes on twitter
falsely claiming that hillary clinton
supporters could vote by sending a text
message to a specific phone number
as a result of the misinformation
campaign prosecutor said at least 4 900
people
or rather 4 900 unique phone numbers
texted the number in a futile effort to
cast votes for mrs clinton
their effort to misinform voters began
after the group saw a similar campaign
intended to deceive voters in the 2016
referendum in britain
on whether the to leave the european
union also known as brexit according to
the complaint
mr mackie and his associates created
their own version sharing photos that
urged mrs clinton's supporters to vote
for her on election day
using a hashtag on twitter or on
facebook
to make the images look more legitimate
they have fixed the logo of her campaign
and linked to her website
some of their memes appeared to target
black latino voters
one image had a black woman standing in
front of a sign supporting mrs clinton
telling people to vote for mrs clinton
by texting a specific number
mr mackey shared a similar image written
in spanish according to prosecutors
okay now back when mackie has dastardly
co-conspirators first
hatched this plan to oppress and injure
the innocent through memes
buzzfeed published a report on the plot
which um included a screenshot of what
those 4 900 people who texted the number
apparently would have received in
response
the clinton campaign sent a reply text
because this was a text going
to the clinton campaign the clinton
campaign sent a reply text
informing them that the ad was not
legitimate
so so there is then no reason to think
that all of those 4900 people
or any of them actually did stay home on
election day under the assumption that
they'd already voted through text
because according to buzzfeed's own
report they were given a message back
saying
that was not legitimate what you saw in
the meme words to that effect
it would seem difficult for the federal
government to prove that anyone was
deprived their right to vote when for
all they know
for all we know the alleged victims did
in fact vote
that of course is all beside the point
the real question is whether it's
actually
possible for a person to be deprived of
their rights or to be injured much less
oppressed
through a meme and the answer to that
would be seem to be no
at least if there is a meme capable of
persecuting all who look upon it
like some sort of horror movie you just
look at the image and you're oppressed
um the ones that mackie posted surely do
not fit that bill i don't know what that
meme would look like i don't know what a
persecuting
oppressive meme would look like i just
know that it doesn't look like this
a constitutional right is infringed
impeded or removed when a person is
through force or threat prevented from
exercising it
nobody was prevented from doing anything
in this case
if there are any rights being infringed
upon it's the first amendment right
of douglas mackey and if any individual
was so unfathomably stupid as to read a
joke meme on twitter and take its voting
guidance seriously
without even doing five seconds of
additional research because that's all
you would need to do
if you're dumb you need to be two levels
of stupid here stupid enough to see that
and not immediately recognize it as a
joke
and then also so stupid that you don't
take five seconds to just google
can i vote through text message that's
all it would have taken
and if you couldn't put in that effort
and you were that stupid
then the fault lies with you
you know now you can't always victim
blame in cases of fraud
um but when the supposed quote-unquote
fraud is a
silly picture on twitter telling you to
vote in a presidential election with a
hashtag
or a text message um yeah the victim
does indeed deserve the blame i am
a hundred percent victim blaming i blame
the victims
totally and i also have zero sympathy
for them
if anything the alleged oppressor has
done us a favor by weeding out the sort
of terminal morons
who shouldn't be voting in the first
place
i realize that's not a valid legal
defense however but
just on a personal note i'm quite glad
anyone who's stupid enough to fall for
something like that i am happy if they
don't vote
thank god they don't vote
now consider the precedent that's quite
intentionally being set here
you know a very common joke on social
media around the time of any election
is for supporters of one candidate to
announce that the supporters of any any
other
are allowed to vote a day late or uh you
know something like that those jokes are
very common
you see them around election day all the
time so
is anyone who made a joke like that now
guilty of a federal crime
if you've made a joke like that on the
internet at any point in your life
are you now liable to go to jail for 10
years i mean does 10 years in prison
sound like a reasonable sentence
even if you agree that it's a crime 10
years which i don't
10 years in prison for that
and if it's now a felony to post a meme
with disinformation
that may influence voting behavior how
far does that go
i mean there are many false or dubious
political claims made in the form of
memes
almost all memes have false or dubious
information
almost everything on the internet does
are we going to prosecute
everyone who posts or retweets one
isn't that the implication here if you
even retweet
a meme that has false information that
may arguably influence the voting
behavior of some people
it's a crime go to jail
but if that's what we're doing why are
we not breaking down the doors of people
who posted claims about donald trump
being a nazi
why are we frog marching them off to
jail that's disinformation
and if believed it could very well
influence how somebody votes
of course um my question is rhetorical
disinformation used against republicans
never has been and never will be
prosecuted mackey's crime
is not that he that he posted
information a disinformation or that he
infringed on anybody's right
but that he did what he did in support
of donald trump
that's the crime the only way around
this conclusion is is the only way you
can get around this
and prove me wrong is if you can point
to leftist meme posters
who have also been arrested or else to
claim that leftists never post dishonest
memes and so that's why they don't get
arrested for them
but there are no examples of the former
and anyone who claims the latter is
guilty of disinformation themselves in
fact
just to prove my point here here is one
example that
this just came to my attention right
before we went on the air um christina
wong
she's an alleged comedian i think
there's some disinformation
in that claim alone but let me show you
a video that
she posted on twitter this is on
november 8th
2016. here's what she posted watch hey
everybody this is christina wong
and uh i'm coming out i'm a trump
supporter
and i just want to remind all my fellow
chinese-americans for trump people of
color for trump
to vote vote for trump on wednesday
november 9th really important day we're
going to show this country
who's boss and that's our man donald
trump so don't forget to vote donald
trump on
november 9th huh
huh see as far as i'm aware
miss wong has not been raided by the fbi
there are no
30-page criminal complaints being filed
against this woman
and that's all you need to know i mean
that that if
if there was any doubt in your mind
whatsoever about whether or not
this new policy this new law is being uh
is being enforced equally well there you
go
we could sit here all day posting give
you similar examples similar jokes like
that
all kinds of disinformation related to
donald trump
much of it not even coming in the form
of means memes but coming from the media
coming in the form of headlines
news articles stories we're not
prosecuting any of that
and that's because there is there has
been for a long time and will especially
be now a two-tier justice system
there's the justice system for the
cultural heretics
and if you're on the right then that's
where you belong you're a cultural
heretic
and there's just system for people like
uh miss wong there
someone who has the correct who believes
in the correct orthodoxy
who has the correct views there's a lot
of things she can do
that you cannot anymore because you'll
go to prison
and saying there's a two-tier justice
system where we have two-tiered justice
that's just another way of saying
we don't have justice in the this
country there is no justice there is no
law
there is but the whims of the elite and
that's the way it's gonna go now
anyone who's not who has not woken up to
that reality
time to wake up listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated